you've been married uh to kyra cedric
who i love as well
um for over 30 years is that right yeah
32. 32
good man that's a good man 32. i got it
right like how
adorable you two are thank you yep she
looks good at least how did you you both
looked good how did you propose
uh i proposed to her on christmas eve
um uh we do uh well back then we were
doing stockings
and so i put the ring in the toe of a
stocking yeah
and so she opened up a bunch of useless
crap and and at the very bottom of it
there was a
uh engagement ring oh my gosh that's
amazing did you
did you tell anyone he didn't tell
anyone no uh i had this feeling that i
really really didn't want anybody else
to know so i didn't tell my friends
i didn't tell family i i no one knew
and uh which meant that i had to go out
and find this ring all by myself and i
have to tell you i'm really not
like a jewelry guy like i just don't get
it i
i'm just not good at picking something
like that out i have to tell you
most men aren't yeah i think it's just
something that
i don't know we just don't have the
training in or or whatever so i was
really but i found this ring and i
thought it was banging
i mean i was like this is this is i i've
i figured it out i conquered this i gave
it to her she was you know
so touched and you know cried said i do
and about three months later
uh we're lying in bed she wakes up in
the middle of the night and she's crying
and she's crying and she
you know she's like you i can't even say
what's going on i'm like oh my god
what's happened i thought maybe she was
breaking up with me or
i don't know what i thought and finally
she goes
i i don't like the ring
so uh yeah i know i talked about the
legislation it's all right it's all
right honey we'll go back i don't care
we'll take it back she's like full and
bawling in the middle of the night
yeah she felt so terrible and you know
the thing was you know why she felt
terrible because she wanted to love it
but then she's like
i'm gonna be stuck with this for 32
years possibly exactly
exactly that's the thing i didn't have
to wear it straight up honesty though
that's bold yeah well after three months
she got honest i mean
it wasn't honest that's still pretty
honest early on just saying yeah that's
that's a hard thing to tell someone so
she really loves you want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure